[музыка]
друзья приветствую вас на сегодняшнем 2
на сегодняшний второй части нашего герба
подкаста посвященный посвященному
кредитам долгам и все всему что связано
с этим мы получили огромный вал реакции
на первую часть нашего геймпа подкаста
Спасибо за все ваши комменты реакции за
шерринги за лайки дизлайки и так далее И
вот сегодня мы продолжаем тему кредитов
и сегодня мы коснемся темы
потребительских кредитов и ипотеки а
также хочу сразу же выразить
благодарность нашему генеральному
партнеру компании Marin Hills
добавкой кардиомарин который
производится в Японии
Итак начинаем
Итак мы продолжаем наш сегодняшний
гемоподказ Я предлагаю сейчас больше
сфокусироваться теперь отойдем от наших
проблем и больше поговорим о проблеме
основной массы населения или
основной будем массе потребительского
кредита кто берет потребитель кредит мы
сегодня снова выяснили что мы не часто
берём потребительский кредит Ну и Боже
берут люди это как правило либо наши
друзья родственники там сотрудники
клиенты и так далее Давайте поразмышляем
именно о потребительских кредитах Они же
для чего-то берут это не так что многие
думают что там или многие размышляют
[музыка]
ситуации человека который берёт кредит
там вот ему захотелось можно сказать
Ну я брал потребительские кредиты и не
раз и перестал их брать только когда
поменял то что вы говорите про мышление
должника к другому реально это такая это
тоже бесконечная Тема ты берешь там на
телевизор или там берешь на телефон
берешь или там на поездку и это
кажешься легкий путь к тому что ты
хочешь
в голове
без каких-либо там условий
мы можем подойти купить там стоит 24
месяца рассрочки бесплатно мы думаем что
дураки что ли не брать 24 месяца
рассрочки бесплатно без переплат еще без
первоначального взноса без
первоначального взноса просто пошли в
банк поинтересовались А зачем Если у вас
есть
деньги в депозит положить который 13
процентов годовых будет приносить и у
меня эти деньги увеличатся еще
не так дело в том что согласен
смотреть внимание слушателей и зрителей
что смотрите бесплатно сыр только
мышеловке это вечная мудрость и когда
телевизор стоит за 100000 тенге или там
за 50 тысяч тенге и там написано
бесплатно 24 месяца на самом деле это не
так это значит процентная ставка уже
туда вшита и этот телевизор вам
обходится тупо дороже чем если бы вы
платили кэш ты не можешь дешевле в этом
моменте
необходимость
Я почему задал вопрос сама необходимость
думать о том что я 24 месяца кому-то
должен за холодильник меня лично
остановит от этой покупки потому что это
надо думать это надо администрировать
какие-то эмоциональные силы в конце
концов
оно неприятное у нас неприятности
когда говорят о потребительских креветах
об уме закредитованности в Казахстане и
так далее Обычно говорят о нужде как о
причинах а первая причина нужда и
кредиты на выживание и Вторая причина
культуры потребления А вот на мой взгляд
эти причины они работают как-то вместе
то есть у нас люди которые находятся в
нужде наверное тоже страдает от культуры
потребления Она из причин нужды у нас
люди которые не находятся тоже страдают
от культуры потребления эти два феномены
их нужно анализировать в совокупности
Они отдельно потому что условно говоря
если каким-то образом чудом избавить
людей находящихся в нужде и это всегда
делается Когда у нас прощают кредиты
Когда у нас масса возвращает кредиты И
тем самым вытягивает людей находящихся в
нужде из этого состояния они берут новые
Почему Потому что они избавились
это проблемы которые в совокупности
решать надо а вот как бы телевизор
и за рассрочку и так далее Это
людей подталкивает на это хотя Или
допустим про то же ту же технику Но вот
зачем вопрос Может у тебя уже есть по
идее нормальный холодильник и он
работает Просто из-за того что там есть
там я не знаю там экранчик лучше он там
по новее И тебе это подталкивает чтобы
купить хотя в принципе у тебя есть ты
можешь пользоваться и лучше накопить и
взять его
в кредит действительно культура
потребление маркетинг
потому что
высокие января
наоборот то есть мы как-то
перепродажники накидываем свою маржу еще
банковской комиссии которые сейчас очень
объемно получается и народ плачет два
раза больше чем должен платить И это для
них оказалась норма поэтому то что вы
подняли эту тему и вопрос Это очень
классно то есть здесь надо что-то делать
и государство будет идеологию или
разъяснение и вот такие люди Как вы
должны Как собирать и наверное
разъяснять людям что кредит это на самом
деле здесь смотрите такой момент с этим
бороться крайне крайне сложные трудно
потому что вся финансовая система
начиная с Америки она построена
потреблении потому что изначально
изначально
человечество живёт Я считаю не по
правильным ценностям потому что главный
показатель
считается рост ВВП
это не что иное как роспотребление
а для того чтобы потребление
всё время росло
с такими штучками Брось старый смартфон
Сейчас появился новый там еще что-то А
так бы Если бы люди пользовались до тех
пор пока смартфон полностью не сдох люди
бы употребляют очень хорошие
вся психология общества всё построено на
росте потребления в Америке
у нас большой но наверное там кредитные
ставки маленькие конкуренции банков
достаточно У нас Мне кажется ставки на
самом деле так смотрите в Америке ставка
пониже Ну и закрытую тебе побольше и на
обучение и на дом Грузии
закончил и ты весь в кредитах Просто у
тебя букет кредитов поэтому
закредитованность это бесконечно они
тебя грузят грузят в этом плане если
воспринимать всю экономику как матрицу
которая порабощает людей это вот это
Потребительская Психология это и есть
основной поработитель людей когда ты вот
смотри чтобы стать свободным человеком
то должен перестать действовать как
другие люди то есть идти на поводу Ну
работает и работает Зачем тебе покупать
новое для этого ты должен заслужить эту
свободу А когда ты идешь на поводу ты
попадаешь в рабство этой матрицы
обязательно
Каждый должен у себя дома Вот у меня
сыну 14 лет
ему говорят
так даже взрослые не могут ответить они
будут себя нереально чувствовать мухами
и бежать новый телефон брать например
контраргумент Телефон это устройство с
которым вы проводите 8-10 часов в день
улучшив его на 20 процентов Вы улучшаете
качество жизни как минимум на 10
процентов
и что мы выиграли мы в течение года
проводили тренинги Мы зарабатывали на
этом деньги Да правильно потом
суббота воскресенье приносили домой и
дома делали кинотеатр для нас для детей
вместе то есть это было выгодно мы как
бы это этот потребительский кредит он
себя оправдал но мы из-за того что это в
семье из-за того что это спокойно
допустимая сумма Как вы говорите мы его
спокойно платили то есть это было не в
напряг
это средство производства скажем так
выбор жены
воспитание детей начинается с выбора
жены Поэтому просто чтобы дети Вот это
во главу угла не ставили а правильно вот
когда он так ответил Я сказала даже
взрослые не могут так ты молодец
[музыка]
очень важно чтобы люди понимание
Осознание мне это нужно Не нужно знать
какой Соблазн особенно у женщин
потратить деньги вот прям потратить это
прям вот
получить удовольствие от шопоголизма у
нас на первом месте стоит и я вот
например когда получилась система
управления деньгами я первую очередь
завела тетрадь где были все даты все
статьи расходов и я каждый день садилась
вечером для меня это было Вот это время
такое
семью покормила всех успокоила ставлю
музыку и вот это у меня Маленькая книжка
есть где записала все расходы за день
вот это все расписывала И когда я
расписывала и говорила себе Ну ты же
могла без этого обойтись Ну ты же могла
без этого
сразу хочу ставить такую ремарку женщины
но скидках деньги не зарабатываются
потому что многие женщины Думают что
если она покупает ненужную вещь со
скидкой в 30%, то она заработала 30
процентов Нет вы потратили 70 очень
важно потому что если есть магазин и
рядом трафик женщины и там написано
Скидка 50 процентов все у них крышу
сносит и женщины воспринимает скидку как
будто она зарабатывает на самом деле это
не так такой большое заблуждение и здесь
хотел бы добавить еще до то что Ильяс
возразил ты правильно возразил но просто
к телефону надо по-разному относиться
если это твой основное средство
производства которое в течение дня с
тобой то понятно Это было должно быть
самое лучшее самое навороченный А если
это просто телефон Проблема в том что
большинство людей покупает смартфоны
используют там 30% функций максимум 30
процентов функций
смартфонов
[музыка]
через 10 лет посмотреть на эти
фотографии скажет
на фотографии детей куча дешевых
смартфонов с идеальными камерами
вот у меня 23
Можно я закончу мысль вот как люди ходят
к вам на фитнес и накачивают себе мышцы
точно также ежедневно заполняя рас
ходы финансовые мышцы ты могла без этого
обойтись То есть ты могла и у меня даже
Одна сотрудница заходя в магазин покупая
одну вещь Она сказала Блин не хочу
вечером это расход писать не буду
покупать
Вот это Соблазн она потихонечку
потихонечку приходит в норму и ты
покупаешь то что тебе нужно ты покупаешь
действительно брендовые вещи Пусть даже
со скидкой где-то Ну вот не 150 платьев
например женщины уберут новые платье не
от того что шифоньер пустой Нет нам
нужно эмоции
и уже
сохранены проблема наших людей не могут
сохранять деньги
Давайте вернёмся к корням
потребительского кредита всё-таки людей
вынуждает нужда
Или все-таки что что первее нужда
вынуждать идти за потребительским
кредитом или психология которая приводит
их в нужду
я отвечу как экономист Я закончил
экономику именно велоси лондонской школе
экономики и вот я являюсь таким
классическим обычным экономистом который
считает там американская модель развития
самая лучшая Да и вся американская
модель она построена на том что без
кредита экономики нету
очень хорошее видео в Ютубе
экономика за 20 минут так вот когда ты
это видео смотришь ты думаешь А как
вообще в Казахстане с таким низким
уровнем
выдаваемости для бизнеса вообще что-то
развивается
[музыка]
все понятные инструменты начинают
доступности кредиты заканчивая просто
рекламой которую все время уговаривает
тебе Ну или как ты думаешь люди Почему
попадают долговые Потому что потому что
мир так за дизайном вокруг них чтобы все
так и было
большинство людей так и будут жить и от
этого экономика будет развиваться И от
этого все вместе мы будем богаче жить то
есть ты говоришь что среда вот
три компонента первое нужно заставляет
лезть долги
второе это среда
которая за дизайна под психологию
человека которая
поощряет говорит что ничего страшного
Это даже хорошо когда же выгоднее это
тебе нужно и так далее
можно сказать Китай не такой да Китай
там развивает производство и так далее
так вот китайцы часто и земпин это
говорит и все собирается отказавшись там
от экспортного экспортной модели
развития перейти на внутреннее
потребление из Китая осознает что это
самый большой экономический инженер и
все Вся политическая как бы
экономическая модель развития Китая на
следующие 10 лет будет основано на
внутреннем потреблении
если мы говорим о скажем так
потребительском поведении понятно что
есть какой-то образец США
Обязательно мы пришли в гости к друзьям
казахско австрийская пара даже никто их
родителям
и
мы там мы Близкие друзья мы там летели
посуду А я кстати не удивился бы до
этого не должно но факт тот что я
поскольку у меня на следующий день
предстояли соревнования я
предсоревновательный период очень много
ем поскольку у меня период углеводной
загрузки как раз
марафон И вот именно вот в этот
предсоревновательный день у меня там по
диете там какой-то колоссальное
количество 17 километров
[музыка]
показательный
с точки зрения тоже это не Бедные люди
сразу обращу внимание Вот те люди у
которых мы были в гостях это врач на
пенсии австрийский врач чрезвычайно
хорошо зарабатывающий всю жизнь это не
Бедные люди это просто другая модель Я
здесь хочу добавить наверное нашей
традиции одно то есть этот
второй то что мешает мне кажется это яд
палат не хуже чем у других третье босики
листы где-то есть вот то-то сделал там
мне надо сделать там там вот этот фактор
как бы влияет
Хотя это негативно
много плохого сделал но в то же время
какие мини Плюсы это удаленная работа
раз и свадьбы начали приглашать меньше
людей скромно делать свадьбы на
маленькие бюджеты Надеюсь сейчас кредиты
на свадьбу меньше берут психологии
чуть-чуть меняется это классно
[музыка]
вот этот пойнтная у меня вот Друг у него
квартиры не было в принципе как бы
достаточно
нормальной семьи и они женились и
родители говорят вот будем Свадьбу
делать и в конце концов Там они
потратили 150 тысяч долларов
это небогатые люди это средний класс
скорее всего кредит там тоже был и он
говорит родителям можно не будем такой
Свадьбу делать Можно нам квартиры
поможете первоначальную сумму дадите и
так далее родители говорят нет Это не
для тебя свадьба Столько людей меня
не собираюсь из-за этого
по полной программе
[музыка]
этика скромности этика труда этика
человека труда в это не очень верится
Потому что ты видишь как это этика
реализовано на примере тех кто ее
провозглашает
всевозможные там журналисты
телеграм-каналы они регулярно публикую
там такой-то там заместитель начальника
милиции отпраздновал там свадьбу там на
потратил на 400 тысяч долларов пример
идут оттуда и так далее и так далее
Потому что Поэтому вот все вот эти
заклинания
все вот эти заклинания какой-то этики
которые в Казахстане преподносится
сверху вниз они работают
Потому что те кто об этой этики говорит
сами
можно сказать
несколько вопросов затронуть первое мне
кажется мир был бы лучше без кредитов
вот касательно там модели Америки
Я как мусульман в исламе кредиты это
храм хоть 01 02 процента это вообще
недопустимо Вот потому что да кто-то
скажет есть хорошие кейсы где там или
заработал еще или там закрыл классно
успешно там за два-три года но никто не
говорит про плохие кейсы потому что
может быть да там может быть там
болезни потому что все же из головы
и ты ходишь переживаешь и от этого может
любые болезни
очень много
последствий может произойти Почему я
тоже против потому что ты когда берешь
вроде бы сейчас
но никто не знает что завтра да Через
год там и с этой техникой может что-то
случиться А тебе отдавать этот долг да
там 24 месяца Да вот или сколько-то
месяцев
или если ты взял 8 под бизнес то его
могут отжать он там имущество может
сгореть а банк ничего не прощает Да
может Договориться можно об отсрочке там
еще как-то Но тяжело это да Договориться
с банком Тем более если это
потребительский в основном банк там
фигачит тебя по полной и это по себе
знаю когда допустим у нас пошли
просрочки просто там вот страшное дело
звонили то есть угрожали и так далее То
что давайте Верните и так далее там жить
не дают тем более сейчас Им дали
инструмент
разного рода инструменты когда блокирует
Поэтому я думаю что есть какая-то модель
развития страны допустим и без кредитов
наоборот Отвечая на ваш вопрос что Я
думаю если это вопрос государству мне
кажется можно было вообще наоборот
усложнить выдачу кредитов второе если
допустим для людей Если вы спрашиваете
надо делать Я думаю что нет ничего лучше
чем собственный пример быть бережливым в
тему пережили как в бизнесе Ну и если
это там просто говорить про себя то
бережливым в дом вопросы
замахиваться на то что ты не можешь вот
поэтому я считаю мое мнение такое
Наоборот я бы если бы есть такая
возможность не брать лучше не брать Вот
давайте быстренько пробежимся я хотел
послушать мнение ержана по поводу
банкротства
физических лиц это тоже хороший
инструмент
с одной стороны что у нас идет большая
закредитованность населения А в то же
время нету необходимого инструмента Если
Вы выбрали эту модель то обязательно
банкротство физических лиц должно быть
вшита в эту систему у нас а грузить
людей система настроена а списывать не
настроено и вот как сейчас ситуация с
этим
есть три причины по которым эти этот
закон так долго обсуждается я сейчас про
них немножко упомяну одна из них
Техническая две такие фактически важны
но в общем
Если говорить о том что сейчас
происходит закон о банкротстве сейчас
его полное название если я не ошибаюсь
Но по-моему так о финансовом
восстановлении и банкротстве физических
лиц сейчас он так называется Почему он
так называется потому что в той редакции
которая вложились по моему ушла в апреле
есть три процедуры первая процедура
называется финансовое восстановление она
применяется тогда когда есть
когда возможность вернуть нет
применяется
а 8 лет проект обсуждается с Апреля 14
три версии было Вот последняя версия
вроде в начале года начали раскачиваться
последняя версия ушла в парламент в
мажились в апреле
что-то Там выступала наша Народная
партиясбаев в июне что-то там он по
поводу выступал этих изменений потом
ушли на каникулы Сейчас есть надежда что
осенью докрутят Но почему не докручивают
8 лет причина первая причина Техническая
не могут пока понять что с этим делать
банкротство предполагает изъятие
имущества А у нас огромное количество
имущества
с этим делать пока понять не могут
потому что можно сейчас в принципе
каких-то непосредственно
и так далее но что делать там с домом в
500 квадратов которые записан там
Наташку пенсионера ваули нет такого
юридического механизма и у формально у
должника может вообще ничего не быть
лучших примеров в мире где-то там
он может себя объявить банкротом
в течение пяти лет кайфовать
наслаждаться как бы этой процедурой и
жить в огромном доме ездить
не будет он зарубеж выезжать запретят
Вот это чисто юридически как и это не
решает скорее всего потому что это ну
как бы вот такая вот особенность А
почему он не принимается есть
разные версии Вот одна из этих версий
это лобби банков и Она состоит даже не в
том что когда введут этот закон о
банкротстве банкам будет сложнее
там с использованием коллекторов как-то
эти средства возвращать банк с этим
справляется у них Вы абсолютно правы у
банков сейчас инструментарий они могут
вернуть Там любой долг безнадёжного
скорее всего принятие этого закона будет
иметь своим прямым результатом
ужесточение процедуры выдачи кредитов то
есть действительно перестанут выдавать
кредиты кому попало
потому что у банки заинтересованы
работают качества
Есть еще одна проблема тоже чисто
Техническая нерешаемая на данный момент
судебное банкротство это как следует из
названия суд
суды казахстанские перегружены если у
нас 1 миллион должников если взять там
Хотя бы пять процентов с ними Завтра
пойдет с исканный банкротства это будет
кошмар коллапса
видимо как-то нужно это По всей
видимости во-первых нужно это на
юридическом
устанавливать
увеличивать количество слуги под это
дело нужна инфраструктура вот как-то так
сейчас обстоят дела И поэтому я честно я
сильно сомневаюсь
Хотя инструмент
необходимый и Абсолютно с тобой согласен
так как сам образование юрист и
прекрасно понимая что одно дело когда
президент сказал и когда дойдет до
конкретных подзаконных актов потому что
закон - это одно там ещё куча
нормативных
которые нужно согласовать со всеми
другими процедурами
закон о банкротстве меняется 21:20 А это
сколько еще ресурсов людских нужно судей
Ну очень много поэтому
направление в принципе правильно но я
тоже
пессимист в плане того что это закон
будет принят быстро но в то же время он
необходим поскольку инфраструктура рынка
по выдаче кредитов она развита она
раскачена без этого сегмента У нас рынок
неполный
все ниши были у нас созданы и коллектора
и там банки фонд проблемных активов А
вот закон о банкротства Нет но я думаю
всё равно мы к этому придём Без этого
никак
подытоживая сегодняшнее сегодняшний
подкаст Дело в том что мы затронули
большие темы все темы большие и кредиты
бизнеса
и так далее
так глубоко проникнуть но мы по крайней
мере я надеюсь дали нашим зрителям
какое-то представление о том как Мы
мыслим что мы думаем и поделились своими
кейсами и я надеюсь что вы извлечете
определенную пользу то что касается
потребителей потребительских кредитов к
сожалению у казахов вот вообще-то есть
три вещи я
и побеждает Вот именно
всегда заканчивается плохо все проблемы
приходят кредиторов с одной стороны
[музыка]
и очень много людей сейчас переходит в
ислам в какой-то мере я думаю что это
поможет в какой-то мере я думаю это
поможет потому что есть страны где не
построены на потребительской модели Ну
возьмем тот же Дубай например но там
другая схема там распределение
национального богатства по-другому идет
ведь на самом деле когда мы говорим о
кредитной системе Это же просто способ
перераспределения денег в обществе есть
налоговая система перераспределения
когда у людей забирают И отдают
госслужащим или малоимущим и так далее
есть кредитная банковская система
И кстати коррупция это тоже система
перераспределения Вот они берут наши
нефтяные доходы потом содержит своих там
лёгкого поведения покупать своим
родственникам рестораны строят кафе
салоны красоты и мы туда ходим и вот
такая экономика это тоже
перераспределение денег и
на банковская система мы к сожалению
Казахстан мы пошли в это направление но
теперь нам изменить я думаю властям
навряд ли удастся но по крайней мере
держать Это в рамках цивилизованных
рамках это вполне возможно и так чтобы
это наносило меньше ущерб нашим нашему
населению И кстати то что такая сейчас
послание сказал что 50 процентов от
дохода национального фонда будет
начисляться детям Это хороший задел
хороший задел это как раз тот
отголосок вот этой системы арабской
системы когда потребительский спрос
стимулировать не за счет кредитов а за
счет капитала вот природной лентой
посмотрим чем это эксперимент закончится
давайте у нас очень мало времени
пробежимся по ипотеке
предприниматели наверное но для меня это
как бальзам на душу был когда вы сказали
что у вас есть алгоритм Когда у вас
просят деньги может его озвучить это
чтобы
у меня есть алгоритм когда кто-то мне
просит о встрече начинается все оттуда
когда кто-то строит меня просят встречи
я уже заранее знаю что когда кто-то меня
просят встречи значит это нужно ему они
мне а раз это нужно ему тогда я сразу
мысленно в голове прокручу что
ему от меня нужно это может быть
потенциально условно мое тело
моя известность
разговор идет о погоде о чем угодно то
знаете разговор идет о деньгах если 10
минут вы не понимаете о чем тема
разговор идет о деньгах просто это мягко
подводят к тому чтобы Как попросить Да
это вступление поэтому когда меня просят
деньги я сразу
проясняют три вопроса первое у меня
просят инвестиции у меня просят долг или
у меня просят помощь я человеку задаю
Вот да я понял ты хочешь от меня
получить там условно 100 тысяч долларов
Скажи в каком виде ты хочешь получить
долг и обычно всегда знаешь я в долг не
даю это принятое мое решение но бывают
такие ситуации что человек
близкий родственник или друг которым ты
отказать не можешь в таком случае я что
делаю Я вот как раз то о чем бы сегодня
говорили сколько я могу дать этому
человеку безвозмездно безвозвратно и
например он просил 100 тысяч Я примерно
у меня рейтинг такой 10 тысяч данных
безвозмездно равны 100000 данных в долг
знаешь я понимаю что у тебя какая-то
проблема но я не хочу быть безучастным
твоим проблеме но в то же время в долг я
не дают поэтому от меня помощь 10.000
всё это безвозмездно безвозвратно чисто
моя дружеская помощь и таким образом
человек как бы чаще всего
удовлетворяется и дальше не просит и
третий вариант Бывает так что человек
Я не имею право ты туда не входишь
второе это садаха это там тоже но я
оказываю это через благотворительную
фонд если у тебя ситуация такая вот
обращайся благотворительный фонд они
тебя окажут обязательно помощь Но я
плачу только туда и третье это
спонсорская спонсорская это на
проведение общественных мероприятий Но
тогда ты должен представить
пакет что ты как Как ты меня
прорекламируешь и на каком количество
аудитории и так далее И когда у вас есть
прописанный алгоритм на каждый случай Вы
можете Легко сказать Нет смотрите
проблема любого бизнесмена большинство
бизнесменов научились зарабатывать
деньги но не умеет говорить нет
вот бизнес состоит из двух вещей
зарабатывать денег и удерживать деньги и
вот большинство бизнесменов которые ко
мне обращаются это те люди которые
зарабатывать но не умеют удерживать и
они умеют удерживать потому что они вот
человек тебе прошел просить ты не можешь
сказать ему нет Если у тебя нет
аргументов для этого если у тебя есть
алгоритм ты всегда можешь сказать Ты
знаешь я не могу тебе дать потому что и
вот эта фраза потому что действует
магический на нас всех Даже американцы
проводили эксперимент когда ставил
длинную очередь человек прибегал и
говорит Можно я без очереди пройду ему
никто не разрешил А когда человек можно
Я пройду потому что мне надо его
пропускали потому что на нас действует
магический потому что у меня правило
иначе вы будете все время все время
распыляться и таким и так много здесь
разговорился давайте мы проговорим
немного про ипотеку давайте так как это
тоже большой сегмент и люди берут
все-таки на жилье и у нас есть истории
Какие Жан брал ипотеку то есть насколько
ипотека необходима
Я лично тоже две квартиры Я вообще
успешный бизнес у меня были разные начал
с продажи квартиры Вот с 14 года я жил
до 22 года в аренде где-то в
девятнадцатом году когда дела Очень
хорошо пошли я купил сначала в Астане
большую квартиру и в Алмате
и это было не ипотека это была рассрочка
от строительной компании одна из них на
7 лет вторая на два года всего
И я очень рад что это было потому что
без этого я единоментно не смог бы на
тот момент вот и вот вокруг есть люди
сотрудники когда кто-либо из них вперед
ипотеку мы все радуемся потому что я
знаю что для моих сотрудников это
единственный способ получить свое жилье
Тем более если это 7 20 25 мы вообще
делаем
который заканчивается К сожалению потому
что семь процентов годовых Это означает
что вы еще зарабатываете на этом Потому
что деньги в депозите 13 процентов
поэтому я двумя руками за ипотеку Чем
более он доступный Мне кажется тем
больше казахстанцев
Я считаю это ипотека это такое тоже
вот отдельные случаи Да вот как ваши
допустим случае это норма Да в плане у
вас это нормально сработало вот в целом
Я против наоборот ипотеки то что это
непонятно что может случиться с
человеком Вот лучше жить по средствам
бережно своим средствам это иллюзия что
это будет твоя квартира также платишь Да
если там это не все позволить себе раз
взять квартиру в рассрочку на два года
Три года в основном это ипотеки такие на
20 25 лет
с ужасными процентами и
это такая у человека который 20 лет или
25 лет
Поэтому лучше наоборот снимать и копить
накопить и купить там небольшую квартиру
Пускай там не в центре города в крутом
ЖК Ну допустим на окраине
это не в кредит Это я думаю что вот этот
надо я думаю развивать терпеливость в
исламе есть терпеливость да И это
наоборот тебя заряжает это тебя
укрепляет Как
ты живешь на зарплату
Ну это же можно копить и копить и копить
и только к концу жизни только накопить
своим детям будет еще лучше Раз уж если
так получилось что у тебя нету тебе не
оставили никто ты в такой ситуации Окей
надо с тобой договориться что довольство
тем что у тебя есть и копить
зарплата там 400 тысяч и жить на 500
наоборот 400 и жить на 200 и откладывать
Я думаю более разумный нормальный
подход потому что непонятно что может
случиться
квартиру заберут потому что все мы
видели
видеороликов когда он убил там
судоисполнителя да там или дранки
какие-то приходят загорает банк да то
есть это же ужасно Вот хорошо Кайрат
если нету крыши над головой Я за за
первую недвижимость Я за и главное не
переборщить То есть у тебя вообще если
нету Ту самую дешевую ипотеку главное
крыши над головой и Аза и я вот против
только вот повседневных ненужных
кредитов это первое потребление
чтобы именно жилье могли люди взять в
ипотеку Почему Потому что в Казахстане
жилье это один из
признаков благосостояния человека
[музыка]
сохранять деньги это очень трудно
Соблазн потратить большой поэтому
сохранять не можем вы правильно сказали
кредиты нас дисциплинирует
есть кредит Мне надо платить Да
сокращаешь расходы И когда у тебя есть
например ипотечный кредит человек
исправно его платит и находит
возможности чтобы его заплатить у него
серое вещество шевелится и он начинает А
вот когда знаете это больше утопия это
демотивирует я никогда Я соберу эти
деньги это больше демотивирует я за
ипотеку за жилье Мне кажется это
стереотип значит
вопрос безопасности
[музыка]
как тогда когда у меня было мои игры
ипотеки Тем более что я абсолютно
позитивно отношусь к аренде Я в аренде
прожил до 28 лет я был последним из моих
друзей кто квартиру последний кто себе
купил желе потому что мне абсолютно было
нормально у меня там не было семьи этом
Сутками на работе сидел Зачем мне как бы
это надо Как только я задумался
необходимость создания семьи я сразу
задумался о том что жилье должно своё и
это мотивирует очень сильно Ты работаешь
работаешь работаешь работаешь
тебе хочется Немножко там как бы
побольше работаешь Я согласен Есть риск
Потому что
есть каких-то чёрных лебедей там короче
ключей
[музыка]
разговор у нас с друзьями лет 12 назад и
условно Вера у всех на тот момент были
ипотечные кредиты на разные суммы как
правило уже хорошие какие-то были
объекты и один друг там что-то я просто
сидим также примерно я краем улавливаю
беседу А я там не вернул этот кредит мне
на него все равно не разрешаешь что ли
он говорит я там не выплачивал да или
три месяца
в голову может прийти мысль я ипотеку
выплачу даже если мне на большую дорогу
придётся пойти я там говорю про кредит
образовательный который я выиграл в 2000
году
он это образовательный он там что-то
просрочил ипотеку говорит я выплачу Я не
знаю что я сделаю я я отдам последние
штаны вот поэтому ипотека она мобилизует
если если чувствуешь себе силы быть
мобилизованным там шесть семь пять шесть
лет около 3 года получается у кого-то 10
сейчас я подержу А мир становится
немножко мобильным люди начинают часто
переезжать работают в разных городах с
этой точки зрения современная молодежи
современные кто сотрудники Им выгодно
жить в аренде мир много сотрудники то
есть в этом городе в этом городе за
рубежом в той стране в той стороны с
этой точки зрения можно не торопиться с
ипотекой и пожить в аренде до
определенного времени
приличная семья с двумя детьми Они
потеряли единство из-за того что вот не
было угла своего Понимаете вот пришел
клиент Они продают новый и вот у детей
нет вот этого привыкание своего
пространства они постоянно это где-то
у детей
[музыка]
Да на старости лет уже вот как говорится
уже под 40 до опять буду опять буду жить
в аренде причем в аренде Я буду жить в
общежитии в студенческом в кембридже
которая стоит 900 фунтов и я сейчас
понимаю что чем ближе эта дата подходит
дикий стресс потому что я последние семь
лет прожил в трехэтажном доме и так
далее совсем другое абсолютно дали
Комфорт себе дикий стресс переходить в
аренду дикий стресс Ну там Ладно условия
Комфорта
дикий стресс
потому что он чем сейчас получается
опять задача
дают страх и мобилизует потому что
действует природный механизм Стимул
страх когда ты хочешь убежать от нищеты
от оплаты от аренды от все и хорошо если
ты убегаешь сторону повышения своих
доходов но к сожалению некоторые люди не
в том направлении убегают а во-вторых
есть бюджетники которые не могут просто
повысить свои доходы
жить им надо поэтому это вопрос такой я
считаю здесь правильного ответа точно
нет мы даже за столом сидим 6 человек
почти
и у каждого траектория судьбы по-своему
складывается Вот я например сам до 2000
года Это мне было
34 года
[музыка]
я обращал внимание и в 2000 году я купил
за 110 тысяч долларов это торговался
продавец только построил дом Он хотел
140 тысяч долларов
за 110 тысяч долларов купил дом у меня
огромный бизнес при этом я за 110 тысяч
купил дом взял кредит в казкоме Потому
что деньги компании это деньги компании
а мои личные траты это мои личные траты
я взял за 110 тысяч долларов понятно там
за полгода потом из дивидендов закрыл но
я купил этот дом и жене сказал что это
временно здесь пожило и мы там прожили
мы переехали 18 18 лет 18 лет и самое
интересное когда у меня было почти 6
миллиардов долларов я жил в доме которые
купил за 110 тысяч долларов и Ко мне
приезжали крупные там люди там и
чиновники большие Акима парус были Аким
областей в гостях они все
спрашивали Это твоя резиденция типа
надо менять дом срочно надо менять
Почему срочно
[музыка]
вот весь там в работе я четко
представляю что для женщин это конечно
наверное очень важно иметь свой угол
поэтому и плюс И вот вы уже упомянули
современный мир такой динамичный Мы
заметили что дети вообще ничего не хотят
ничем владеть
и там живут в разных странах Они меняют
они более это мобильные в разных странах
живут сегодня Здесь завтра там
и мир меняется поэтому
правильный точно рецепт мы наверное
сказать не можем по ипотеке Это
правильно или неправильно надо каждый
раз смотреть На ситуацию на финансовую
ситуацию на то чем занимаешься У кого-то
это получается у кого-то
для кого-то это высочайшая
ответственность
вот можно скажу Вы сейчас сказали про
Страх Страх потери создает жажду
приобретения вот Я вот сижу Кайфую от
ваших слов сейчас поедете Да это создаст
вам нужен страх потери создает жажду
приобретения и в тебе начинает выходить
новые силы потенциал то что ты даже от
себя не ожидал мы даже не знаем иногда
На что мы способны Есть такой момент
Этот бассейн полный крокодилами и Царь
говорит Кто проплывет Этот бассейн два
варианта либо он получает пол царство
либо он получает мою дочь совсем царство
и только он не успел сказать
отбивается общем короче еле-еле выходит
в эту сторону
и Царь подбегает говорит вам нужно пол
царства он говорит нет Значит вам нужно
Моя дочь и Все царство Нет а что же там
Тогда нужно Я хочу найти того гада кто
меня толкнул этот постепенно
это но он проплыл если быстро для
начинающих предпринимателей Стоит ли
открывать бизнес беря кредит
Можно я свою историю которая готовил
когда мы начали развивать инвиктус у нас
сразу все хорошо пошло и естественно как
новый бизнес мы не могли брать кредит
Потому что его нам никто не давал мы
всегда были в аренде У нас не было
залога и мне приходилось
продавать долю компании внешнему
инвестору и
инвестиции используют чтобы расширять
компанию
Мы подумали Окей Мы уже большая компания
вот есть отличный проект просто по
финансовым показателям он будет еще
лучше да это огромный клуб в Астане
кстати построить и у нас вот есть
примерно миллион долларов мы миллион
долларов сделаем на предпродажах нам
нужно миллион долларов
миллиона долларов которые нам нужно 500
тысяч гарантирует дому снижает ставку в
тенге до 7 процентов дому все одобрил и
теперь с этим одобрением я иду там Халык
Я иду Сбербанк я иду к своему другу
я не смог получить кредит потому что они
у меня требовали во-первых личных
гарантий во-вторых Еще 80 миллионов
тенге положить на депозит на 5 процентов
годовых чтобы первые несколько месяцев и
в-третьих они просили чтобы все бизнесы
которые у меня есть и были я заложил
за миллион долларов просто 10 миллионов
долларов залогов
Либо так и даже Если друг не мог это
плохая история и вы не можем в
Казахстане развиваться Поэтому нам
пришлось там изобретать что вот теперь
мы по франчайзингу другая история мой
друг он в Дубае поехал думал чем
заниматься открыл квест комнаты потому
что окастов в Казахстане они уже развиты
были в Дубаях не было к нему приходит
предприниматель с Австрией Как клиент
блин это классно у нас в Австрии тоже
нет Австрии кстати
[музыка]
франчайзинг Я не знаю франчайзинг но я с
тобой вместе открою Давай они в Австрии
открывают первую точку она у них хорошо
идет и тут банк приходит им дает короче
типа
какая-то ставка плюс там 0,75 и вот это
какая-то ставка на отрицательная была
они по 0,5 процентов гарантируется
никакие залоги не нужны ничего не нужно
они открывают вторую третью точку
стартап который только только открыл и
этот бизнесмен австрийский потом
начинает с ним хитрить на этом все
Мерседесы покупать на компанию там и так
далее но просто насколько доступны
кредит дает возможность бизнесу
развиваться во-первых быстро во-вторых
не теряя своей доли А у нас единственный
способ развития в Казахстане только
экоте Да инвестор Не ну даже неплохо
брать инвесторов брать партнеров это же
классно я разделять риски
определяется уровнем доверия
между гражданами Доверие между
институтами
очень низкие любая мало развитая страна
приезжаешь много заборов много Security
много шлагбаумов это все низкий уровень
доверия и плюс Когда в экономике низкий
уровень доверия вот происходит Вот так
мы сами себя откладываем банки не
кредитуют экономику потому что не
доверяет предпринимателям
предприниматели не доверяют
правительству государства и банка И вот
ну это проблема нашего общества здесь
уже ничего даже не решение правительства
это не так что президент сегодня
послание сказал что надо найти способы
а как способы Нацбанк найдет если с
одной стороны любой способ послабления
даст через день фимпол придет к ним
у нас же еще есть сети которые
зарабатывают на том что находят проблемы
Да И вот эта проблема то что
правоохранительные органы это целая
система построена на том чтобы в стране
было много взяток много коррупции и так
далее Это как вот знаете как система
врачей которые заинтересована в том
чтобы
пациенты болели или юристы
а то что касается кредита на развитие
бизнеса с одной стороны
не было доступа к кредитам вы как-то
извратились нашли способ через франшизу
и так далее Но это же вас не остановило
вы пробились знаете есть такая
Экономическая теория Она дурная сразу
скажу чтобы меня не хейтили Она дурная
но она интересна по-своему она гласит
такая Экономическая теория один
американец сказал что бедным надо бедных
надо гасить а богаты надо максимально
дать льгот
и все такие Ты что дурак что ли а он это
математика очень простая Чем больше мы
будем богатых создавать условий тем
быстрее будет деградировать их потомки
соответственно
эти деньги чем больше трудностей мы
создадим для бедных тем сильнее они
будут пробиваться жизни в них будет
сильнее
они будут стремиться наверх и достигать
больших высот это теория такая
потому что вижу среди своих друзей что
как правило крутых достижений достигают
те которые Чем глубже с какой-нибудь
тем дальше стреляет
[музыка]
один из кредитов хорошо или плохо тоже
непонятно
С одной стороны если брать Ислам конечно
Ислам против кредитов Ислам всячески
оберегает человека проблем от тех
проблем которые человек сам себе еще и
создает потому что любой кредит это
внимание отвлечение внимания Это большой
источник высасывания энергии из тебя
который ты мог бы направить подумал Вот
смотри Разница в том что когда у тебя
доступный кредит ты не включаешь голову
а только ты у тебя нету доступа кредита
ты начинаешь включать голову Вот и вся
разница то есть сделать доступным кредит
люди начнут
по автомату его брать а нету кредита
люди начинают думать
Потому что это не убивает них мотивацию
они хотят хорошо жить но они начинают
думать включать голову А что можно
сделать А что вот она рассказала историю
только она попала в такую проблему
ситуацию первым что она включила голову
включается голова
начинает пахать он начинает думать и так
далее
10 лет я давала энергию этой мысли она
увеличилась
[музыка]
человека одинаково одеты одинаковые
одинаково возраста даешь этому миллион
этому миллион через через три месяца у
этого опять нет денег а этот делает уже
миллион триста то есть возвращать потому
что у него мышление бедного человека
сколько бы ты не давал он будет это
тратить и даже не подумает об
ответственности а этот увеличит себе
возьмет и тебе вернет То есть это
отмышление очень много зависит поэтому я
вот переключилась тех пор даю энергию
только доходов Давайте на этой
оптимистичной ноте мы подведем черту мы
сегодня еще раз подчеркнул затронули все
аспекты кредитной деятельности
[музыка]
либо потребление и так далее поделились
своими историями поделились своим опытом
Надеюсь было полезно Надеюсь вы из этого
что-то извлекаете для себя еще раз
подчеркнул что не существует
универсальных рецептов
должен решать в меру своей ситуации Я
например лично сторонник того чтобы не
брать кредиты я так как правоверный
мусульманин Я полностью поддерживаю
точку зрения Ислама что кредит харам и
брать его плохо и это всегда может
привести к беде но существует разные
Различные точки зрения это плюрализм
мнений у каждого своя история не могу
сказать что правильно что неправильно в
Моем Мире брать кредиты долги личные Тем
более это неправильно
Останемся каждый при своем мнении
Спасибо вам что вы нас смотрели Кому
было интересно этот сезон открыт это 2
сезон Подписывайтесь внизу ставьте
колокольчик Ну вот эти все традиционные
прибамбасы и обязательно подпишитесь ко
всем участникам которые здесь мы снизу
дадим ссылки на их аккаунты в социальных
сетях
[музыка]